hey you guys flickers of fear time
the movie i'm talking about today is
kind of like i feel like this is really
a something of a forgotten gem and it's
i really don't know why
a lot of people don't talk about this
movie
and the crazy thing too is that which i
didn't actually find out until i went uh
researching a little bit more about it
was that this movie had a vhs release
for sure back in the late 80s but it
never got a dvd release and it only got
a blu-ray release in 2016 even though
this movie came out in 1988 which is
crazy to me because this is actually a
really really good movie now what ended
up happening with this uh film like how
i ended up talking about it this week
it's called jack's back by the way uh
starring james speeder
now i actually saw this movie probably
back in 1990 or 1991 i'm pretty sure i
rented it from like our mom and pop
video store or it's possible i could
have seen it on cable but i'm pretty
sure that i saw the vhs cover i'm pretty
sure that i rented it because i like
james spader and uh you know it's touted
as something being sort of like jack the
ripper so i was like oh two things that
i like very much how can that go wrong
and indeed it didn't it was a very good
movie
so uh so i saw it a couple times back
then i think i maybe
you know when i rented it like back in
the old days i had the dual deck vcrs
and before they had all that macro [ __ ]
like where you couldn't record [ __ ] um i
used to rent stuff from the video store
and then you know if i liked it i would
make a copy for my own self and i'm
pretty sure that i did that with this
one too so i saw it like several times
in the late 80s and or rather the early
90s
and then i kind of like forgot about it
now probably about a year ago i was
flipping through flipping through
scrolling through
so you can tell i'm old because i still
talk about things as they're like
physical medium so i was scrolling
through 2b
and i noticed that they had jack's back
on there and i was like oh [ __ ] i
remember that movie uh maybe i should
like uh you know watch that and review
it so i wrote it on my absurdly long
list and i said okay well i'll get
around to it eventually and then a few
months ago i actually started watching
it but then i got like distracted and
then i ended up doing another movie that
week so i didn't do it but then just
like last week or the week before i got
a message from a listener and was like
oh you should totally do jack's back and
i'm like funny you should mention that
uh i'd actually been wanting to do that
for about a year and i said might as
well do it right now because it's still
on tubey who knows it's been on there
for a while so i don't know how much
longer it's going to be on there
but yeah this is actually like a really
really good movie and i just feel like
it's
really kind of sadly underrated i think
maybe the problem too because when this
came out
um i don't think it was like hugely
expensive to make but i think it only
made like half of its budget back and it
didn't even really get that good of
reviews although cisco and ebert liked
it so they both thought it was great
which it is i think part of the problem
i don't think the problem was that it
was a bad movie i think the problem was
that it was a little bit mismarketed
so as i said the movies about jack
is called jack's back
and the trailer for it made it seem as
though this was like a slasher or like a
serial killer movie like about
it almost kind of implied that james
spader was going to be playing someone
who was like reincarnated jack the
ripper who was like a killer and stuff i
kind of feel like that was the vibe
that a lot of the marketing and the
trailer and stuff put off
and that's absolutely not what this
movie is yes there is a killer in it
that's
you know like a copycat jack the ripper
killer and that is going on but
it's almost kind of like a background
this is actually more like a
hitchcockian
crime thriller with a little sprinkling
of maybe paranormal you know what i mean
so
uh if you haven't seen it
i would recommend that you go to 2b and
watch it because
while i might not well i probably won't
spoil the ending like who the killer is
and stuff like that
it's really hard to talk about this
movie because it has like a lot of
twists and turns it's really hard to
talk about this movie
past like the 20 minute mark um without
spoiling some [ __ ] that's you know
several of the twists and turns that it
takes so it's really so i'm gonna have
to spoil some things because otherwise i
would have to stop talking like right
now
about it and i don't really want to do
that and like i said i don't know i'm
i'm kind of of two minds about spoiling
things because this movie it's old i
mean it came out in 1988 but i do kind
of feel like maybe a lot of people
haven't seen it and this is a movie that
because it's a crime thriller because
it's twisty turny it's probably better
to go into it not knowing any of the
twists and turns like not knowing any of
the plot points because i don't think
it'll ruin it because it's still like a
good movie anyway like the acting and
stuff but it is better like not really
knowing where it's going because there's
a lot of like surprises in it
so uh so as i said this is
a marginally uh a jack or rather like a
jack the ripper copycat type story but
that's very much like in the background
so what you have oh and i should say too
that jack's back was not actually the
original title of this it was actually
supposed to be called
red rain named after the peter gabriel
song because they actually wanted the
peter gabriel song to be like the theme
but i guess they you know this was a
lower budget production and they
couldn't afford to get the rights to
that song so they decided they were just
gonna change it to jack's back and like
i said market it more like a slasher or
a horror movie like about a serial
killer which it's really not i forgot to
mention too
that this was actually the directorial
debut
of rowdy harrington now if you know that
name he's probably best known for
roadhouse now
i love roadhouse but don't think that
this movie is anything like roadhouse
it's really not because roadhouse is
just like so cheesy and ridiculous and
fun
this one is much more like i said much
more hitchcocky and like a dark brooding
almost noirish uh kind of thing so it's
really doesn't have hardly anything in
common with roadhouse i think that he
made uh he also made striking distance
i've seen some other reviews of this
that said that this was james spader's
first starring role i don't think that's
the case i think he'd actually had a
starring role in a movie back in 85 and
of course he was in a lot of um you know
he was in pretty in pink and
all that kind of stuff so i had seen him
in a bunch of [ __ ] like prior to him
seeing this which is why i wanted to see
this movie because i was like oh james
spader i love that guy and i also like
because i kind of feel like particularly
because of pretty in pink and less than
zero and like a lot of stuff that he was
in in the mid 80s he kind of got type
cast as like
arrogant yuppie douche um which he's
very good at playing that i'm not saying
that but he didn't get a lot of roles
like outside of that but if you want to
see him
do something completely different and to
play against type and actually play dual
roles in this
um then definitely check this one out
because he's actually a great actor when
he's not
type cast into that role like i said he
was he played a good arrogant yuppie
douche i'm not saying that but
it was interesting to see him play
pretty much a completely different kind
of character i think one of the
characters he plays in this actually
kind of reminds me more of like the
character he played from stargate so you
know kind of that type of dude
but like i said he plays uh dual roles
in this he plays twin brothers
so all right so here we go with this
plot and like i said it's very twisty
turny i'm not going to spoil everything
like i probably won't spoil like the end
who the killer is and stuff but i'm
gonna have to spoil some plot beats you
know just in order to discuss the movie
so when we first start out as i said in
the background so it's 1988 so it's
actually the 100th anniversary of the
jack the ripper murders and in los
angeles some serial killer has got it
into his head that he's going to
perfectly recreate
all of the original jack the ripper
murders like on the same date that it
happened he's going to do the same
mutilations and he's gonna do all that
so he's been doing that and the cops are
not able to catch him so that's kind of
going on you know in the background
james spader uh plays a guy named john
westford now he's a med student i don't
think he's finished medical school yet
but he's still doing residency or
whatever the hell
and he uh i guess he grew up like in
kind of a poor neighborhood and he's a
very um he's a very good person he's
very humanitarian he's very uh cares
about the poor
and so he actually works in a free
clinic like in the you know very
financially strapped neighborhood where
he grew up because he wants to give back
to the community he's also very um
he's an advocate for the homeless and
stuff kind of they show him uh talking
to all these people like in the you know
the hobo camps or whatever the hell you
want to call them uh you know tent
cities and like trying to advocate for
their care and things like that and he
goes and takes care of them for free so
like i said he's he seems like just a
really
good dude i mean there's like nothing
you know negative about him at all he's
just a really sweet guy who cares about
other human beings
so he works at this clinic with this
other young woman named uh chris i think
her character name is now she's played
by cynthia gibb she was in a bunch of
stuff she was in that uh what's that
burt reynolds movie that we talked about
the other day the matinee one she was
actually really really young and it
wasn't gator it was uh
now i can't remember what it was but
but yeah so she was uh in that as well
so she's kind of like uh you know
friends with him and he's got some other
friends at the at the clinic and
everything like that
now the guy that runs the clinic is
[ __ ] you know what i mean yeah dr
sydney that's his name so uh so yeah so
he's the guy that runs the clinic and he
just does not have any patience for any
of this like humanitarians like you know
[ __ ] the poor all that kind of stuff and
he also has like a real like moral kind
of streak where like this woman comes in
and she's pregnant and i guess she wants
an abortion or something like that and
he's like you should think about your
life choices
so you know he's excoriating her and um
so so there's that and james spader is
just kind of like all right whatever
so
uh so basically what happens is that
he's worried about uh the pregnant woman
and he knows her
i think he knows her because there's a
picture of what looks like him and her
like in a picture together
but you find out later like i said that
he has a twin brother so i'm thinking
that maybe because she comes out of the
office after getting yelled at for
wanting an abortion and she looks at
james bader like holy [ __ ] i know you
and she's like oh and he's like holy
[ __ ] i know you but they don't
i think the implication is that that was
maybe
i don't think it was his ex-wife i think
it was his ex like sister-in-law or
something i could be totally wrong about
that but she either knows him or she
knows his twin brother
so he's kind of like worried about her
so he finds out where she lives and
she's he's gonna go like check on her
and uh it so happens that these the jack
the ripper serial killer that's been
going around he's gotten to the last uh
you know the last kill which is you know
the most gruesome one the girl that was
killed inside of her room and that girl
was actually
a month pregnant or something like that
i can't remember like in real life was
she actually a month pregnant or did
they actually
not i don't know was that something that
they thought in the 80s and that's not i
don't remember but anyway in the movie
they say
yeah the the girl was a mother pregnant
so we know he's gonna kill a person like
that we just don't know who it is and we
know when the date's coming up because
like i said all the dates matched up
with the original jack the
murders
so he goes to check on this patient
and when he gets there
uh he discovers that she has been
she's the murder victim she was like
horribly horribly mutilated now while
he's there he runs into
this guy who's like a i guess he's like
an orderly like at the clinic that he
works at
and he and he's like what the [ __ ] are
you did you like so you're jack the
ripper and he's like no no i just came
to give her an abortion like on the down
low and you know then i saw you and i
ran away
and he's like yeah a likely story if it
was like this big chase
and uh upshot of it is about half an
hour into a movie into the movie uh the
original james spader whose character's
name is john the nice doctor guy he gets
into a fight with this orderly who is
maybe jack the ripper
uh so they get into a fight and john the
james spader nice guy
he gets killed like but in a way that
looks like and as he makes it looks like
look like he hung himself
and then he sort of like does a little
bit of a frame up sort of [ __ ]
um so it looks like you know this
humanitarian doctor was actually jack
the ripper
and then he was done like you know with
the series and so he hanged himself so
the cops are like woohoo you know well
one more girl got killed but oh well
case closed you know what i mean
so the weird thing about this i had
forgotten like i remembered sort of like
the jack the ripper aspect and i
remember james spader being it but i
didn't remember like all the twists and
turns of the plot so when i'm watching
it again like half an hour in james
spader gets killed and i'm just like
wait he can't is he dead or is it
they killed james vader like halfway is
this psycho what the [ __ ] is going on so
there was that
but then it's like so he hangs and he
and he's dead and i'm like okay there he
can't be alive because i kept thinking
that he was gonna like pop back and like
be alive and but he wasn't
so then they cut to
james spader like waking up in bed like
he's having a nightmare like holy [ __ ]
so for a second you think oh the first
like half an hour or that whole sequence
of him like chasing the maybe jack the
ripper and like getting hanged that you
thought that that was like a dream
but no it turns out that this james
spader is john's twin brother rick ricky
richard they call them like different
things so this is the twin brother now
like i said this doesn't come out of
thin air
um i had forgotten this but they do
actually set it up like at you know at
the very beginning like john's having a
conversation with this old lady that's
come into the clinic and and she asked
him about his family he says oh i've got
a brother but i don't really talk to him
or anything like that and they do
actually show him in his apartment and
there's like pictures of two little boys
that are clearly twins so it's not like
they just like completely like woo
there's a twin they did like set it up
it's just if you didn't know that ahead
of time it wouldn't like register
necessarily so i thought that was like a
really good touch like really good
writing because then you go back and
you're like oh yeah he did mention that
he had a brother that he didn't talk to
so the twin brother has apparently had
you know because twins supposedly have
that kind of like psychic connection
type [ __ ] they don't say psychic really
in the movie
but you know this character rick
you know he looks exactly the same
obviously because it's still james
spader but he's a little bit of a
different he's not a bad guy he's still
a good dude
but he's a little more
you know he's a little more of a bad boy
type like he's made some questionable
choices in his life um you know he's a
little edgier he's a little angrier um
he's kind of a little bit more
like scrappy in the sense like and he
hangs out like it with a lot more
you know certain like sort of seedy
uh type of areas and it's maybe implied
that uh he's not always exactly on the
right side of the law like he's not a
murderer or anything but just kind of
like minor [ __ ] wears a leather jacket
and stuff like that now i will say that
james spader like doing the dual roles
in this is so good and it's not kind of
like because you know how sometimes you
see movies with an actor like playing
twins
and they'll try to
you know really really differentiate
between the two characters and they'll
kind of go too far with it this is not
like that you can absolutely tell these
are two different characters but he
plays it it's pretty low key it's just
in a lot of things like just kind of the
way he his facial expressions the way he
moves his body um stuff like that but
it's just really you know just even that
the stare that he has like he's a lot
more intense as as rick so it's a great
performance i mean i think it's pretty
much you know right up there with jeremy
irons and dead ringers where you know
they
it's it's just like a really subtle
thing but you can absolutely tell
they're two completely different people
and i think he like he did a really good
job and that's what i'm saying
you know it's kind of a shame that in
the 80s he got typecast
james bader got typecast into these you
know type of arrogant yuppie dish rolls
because you know when he was in this he
was actually like really really good
this is one of his best films i think
so
rick has
what he presumes is a vision or a dream
of his brother's death
now
he's like he tells the police he's like
you know you're gonna think this is
really stupid but he's like i i saw it
in a dream
and they asked him they obviously don't
really buy it but they're like okay well
obviously you're his twin brother
because you look just like him
and
they're like well has weird [ __ ] like
this happened to you before and he's
like not really he's like one time when
we were kids like we
uh we were in this class and we took the
test
and our tests were exactly the same like
all the mistakes and everything and so
the teacher thought we had cheated off
each other
so um made us take the test over again
like in separate rooms and the same
thing happened so obviously they had
some kind of connection but
he's like that's really the only weird
thing that's happened he's like nothing
like this has happened to me before
um but he's like i'm telling you right
now that my brother was absolutely not
the jack the ripper killer and someone
murdered him and made it look like
suicide and i saw the person
in my vision and i'm gonna find out i'm
gonna get to the bottom of it
so the cops like i said they don't
really believe him
um they kind of do but then they're just
kind of like well i don't know this
sounds really bullshitty and there's
like well maybe you're the killer and
you killed your brother and you're
trying to like do this whole frame up so
they start following him around as well
because they think he's like pretty sus
so
uh so he kind of enlists the help of
chris the young woman at the uh the
clinic who was friends with her brother
she believes him and so they kind of do
a little bit of sleuthing like on their
own to try to figure out like uh who the
killer is so he can clear his brother's
name
because you know like i said the cops
are
operating under the assumption that his
brother was the killer or that he's the
killer and he killed his brother but
like i said he knows
he saw the dude's face he saw the dude
that killed um the the clinic orderly
that killed his brother now you don't
know if that guy was actually the ripper
or if he really did go to that girl's
apartment to give her an abortion and
then
you know john turned up and you know he
freaked out and then they had a fight
and he's like okay well i'm just gonna
kill you so but he's like well i for
sure saw that guy
and he sees like a picture like in his
brother's apartment of you know the
clinic staff and he's like that's the
guy that's the guy that was in my you
know that was in my uh vision so
they kind of look into that as well but
like i said there's lots of like twists
and turns after that but it's just it's
so great like i said it's like a psycho
moment because you're only like 20 30
minutes into the movie and the main
character you've been following this
whole time he's suddenly dead you know
what i mean and i'm sitting there going
what you can't
you can't put james spader on the
[ __ ] cover and like then just kill
him off like half an hour but what the
[ __ ] are you doing
and uh so i was like well he can't be
really dead and i'm like oh i guess he
is really dead because he was man he was
just [ __ ] hanging there but then yeah
so then they bring in the twin brother
element which i had completely forgotten
about
um you know i'd forgotten that plot
point like entirely uh but yeah so
if you have not seen it if you really
like james bader if you really like like
i said it's not a horror movie it's got
some serial killer stuff it's got like
some gore like um when he finds the you
know the uh the pregnant lady that's
been killed um it's kind of gory and
yucky like it's kind of it's not as bad
as the real if you've ever seen the real
uh crime scene photos like the jack the
ripper the last victim where she was
just like completely
butchered and
eviscerated and there was just like
intestines everywhere and [ __ ] like that
it's not that bad but it's kind of gory
but it's not
it's not really a horror movie i would
call it
it's more like a noirish like crime
thriller
with like a serial killer horror kind of
aspect to it but it's really really good
like this it's very suspenseful it's
shot really nice like i really like like
i said it's very kind of smoky and
warish and it's got that um kind of
saxophone like late 80s
kind of
almost like the erotic thrillers that
would come out like in the 90s like
after basic instinct and all that it's
got that kind of vibe to it but yeah
it's really really good and
i just wish that
it was better known
um i wish that they had maybe marketed
it better back in the old days i do kind
of feel like even the cover art on the
box
the cover art is basically just like a
picture of james spader like looking
kind of like that and then you know the
title jack's back and that's it
you don't really you can't really tell
like what kind of but like i said it's
almost implying oh james spader is jack
the ripper like he's reincarnated as
jack the ripper or he's a serial killer
or something like that and that's not
really how it goes
i think maybe
uh you know jack's back is a good punchy
title
but i think that it was kind of
misleading in the sense that it made
people think that the movie was going to
be about a jack the ripper killer and
it's not exactly that that's just kind
of going on in the background and it's
sort of like the jumping off point for
this whole thing where this dude's
trying to like clear his brother's name
because his brother gets accused of
being this killer so it's mostly about
him and about like the investigation and
you know this kind of twisty turny like
murder mystery so it's not so much about
the serial killings it's not a slasher
it's not anything like that i kind of
feel like maybe
they should have called it red rain like
they wanted to like even like i love
that song and it would have been awesome
if they could have got that song they
actually they wanted that song they
couldn't afford it so they had like a
songwriter write a song kind of like it
that's called red harvest which is a
perfectly good song but i do kind of
wish that even if they hadn't been able
to get the rights to the peter gabriel
song maybe they should have called it
red rain i don't know but then there was
that other there was that movie called
black rain
that was uh
ridley scott was that ridley scott or
tony scott
i think it was ridley scott and uh when
did that come out but the year before
this year after this now i can't
remember but yeah so maybe they were
like oh it's like too similar but i
think that if they had given it a title
that didn't have jack in it then maybe
it would have done better because people
would have just seen it as you know like
a crime thriller instead of expecting it
to be about jack the ripper you know
what i'm saying so
anyway but yeah it's it's really kind of
a shame because this is actually a
really really good movie one of the best
crime thrillers from this era from that
year and it just seems like a lot of
people don't talk about it like i said
it never even got a dvd release like not
in the united states and as far as i
could determine uh you know it only just
got a blu-ray release in
2016. i think it's got some
extras on it but not a great deal from
what i could uh determine i think
they're they had rowdy harrington and i
think he did a commentary track but i
think it's just him i don't think they
have james spader on there but yeah so
it doesn't have a lot of extras like i
said it just seemed like it came out it
didn't do all that well like it didn't
make any money and then it just sort of
went to vhs a couple people like me
picked it up because like i said hey
james bader um and then it just kind of
got forgotten about like for years and
years so hopefully now that it's out on
blu-ray um it'll get rediscovered like i
said it's on 2b as of this recording uh
and i definitely do recommend it it's
actually like a really good really
suspenseful thriller and you know if
you're into james bader and you want to
see something
him being a character that he didn't
usually play like in the 80s like
playing a little bit against type then
this is absolutely worth watching let me
know if you've seen it if you saw it
back in the old days like i did and then
just kind of forgot about it until you
saw it come up on to be it's it's
definitely worth watching so go check it
out if you haven't seen it if you have
seen it let me know what you thought
about it in the comments and that will
do it for this flickers of fear i will
see you guys on the next one bye